interdire ça n'est pas empêché et c'est
là que je crois que il ne faut pas que
la loi se mêle de trop de choses et il
faut laisser faire ce que j'appelle la
conscience morale et aussi le jugement
du juge alors j'ai préparé la citation
de Paul Ricard que je voulais vous
donner elle est pour moi une boussole
s'il faut avouer j'ai eu la chance le
privilège de m'entretenir beaucoup avec
lui de cette question s'il faut avouer
que les pratiques clandestines
d'euthanasie
sont inéradicables ce que je crois donc
aucun pays la loi n'a empêché les zones
grises et même on peut aller plus loin
selon les deux études scientifiques dont
je dispose le détendre l'anglais l'autre
est en français il y a plus d'euthanasie
clandestine en Belgique
proportionnellement la population qu'il
y en a en France il y en a en France
bien entendu s'il faut avouer que les
pratiques clandestines d'euthanasie
active sont inéradicables et si
l'éthique de détresse est confronté à
des situations où le choix n'est pas
entre le bien et le mal mais entre le
mal et le pire alors même le législateur
ne saurait donner sa caution le
législateur ne saurait donner sa caution
et il ajoutait Paul Ricoeur a-t-on
oublié la réflexion d'Aristote sur
l'équité confiée aux sages lorsque la
loi trop abstraite et trop générale ne
peut plus prononcer une parole de
justice dans une situation concrète
marquée par l'urgence et la détresse
le dernier philosophe que j'aimerais
citer ces Chester Stone philosophe
britannique qui dans un livre sur le
génie paru en 1922 avait eu cette
formule que j'ai voulu placer enfin
en épigraphe du livre que j'ai préfacé
de soignants belge qui disent pourquoi
ils ne pratiquent pas l'euthanasie
l'edanazil envers du décor je l'offrirai
au rapporteur j'ai voulu placer cette
phrase de chesteron qui dit une loi
produit toujours des fruits bien au-delà
de ce qu'elle avait cru circonscrire au
départ il le disait déjà à propos de
l'eugénisme en 1922 il le redirait
nécessairement aujourd'hui ce que je
redoute c'est que en répondant à une
demande
que je ne conteste pas dans le corps
social mais qui n'est pas une demande
médicale des personnes réellement dans
l'immense majorité des cas en souffrance
en répondant à une demande on crée en
même temps une offre qu'il ne soit
permis ici de dire que dans les pas de
ma maman a décidé d'aller elle va avoir
100 ans bientôt si jamais d'aventure
elle apprend que c'est une offre qu'on
lui fait parce que forcément elle lit
les journaux elle regarde la télévision
comment moi son fils mes frères et
soeurs qui l'accompagnant au quotidien
nous allons nous
continuer à lui donner le goût de vivre
ce qui pourtant est pour un fils par
rapport à sa mère vous en conviendrez le
non seulement un devoir mais tout
simplement la preuve d'affection que
nous devons je redoute que la
normalisation des esprits qui est en
cours en ce moment au Canada en
particulier ou 7% des décès sont
pratiqués par euthanasie en Belgique ou
ça croit régulièrement ou les
restrictions de départ sautent les unes
après les autres je redoute que en effet
nous rentrions dans une civilisation qui
n'est pas celle que Michel vaccès que je
veux encore citer ici un peu lourdement
parce que un thé de gauche c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui n'est pas suspect de
rouler pour le Vatican et donc je trouve
que il faut faire attention à ce que
l'on est en train de mettre en place en
matière de modification de nos
représentations